yeah yeah come on come on
[Music]
okay
hi what's your name gabriela gabriella
and um
are would you consider yourself a
feminist no
i'm surprised i've had so many people
come up and say they aren't feminists
why do you think that is
i don't know maybe they don't want to
look bad because if you say that you're
not a feminist then you're bad and so
when i went out to do interviews i
really was encouraged by how many people
actually agreed with me and didn't
believe in feminism or identify as a
feminist when i originally went out i
thought that everyone was gonna just
disagree and be mad but it was really
cool to see that you know maybe not all
western women are lost
but i don't think i just don't want to
be associated with the word it doesn't
mean that i don't identify with some of
the things that feminists
say i just think there's a lot of like
prejudice
about feminism in general because of
yeah as you said like sometimes they get
very offended or like the attitude i
just don't like it
what do you think feminism is fighting
for in 2022
i mean they advocate for equality but
sometimes they
it's not really equality is it it's just
not very balanced sometimes
so
you know some things that you were
saying like i don't like that woman
wants so many rights but like a few
things that are
considered
normal in society like the man has to
pay for dinner or the man has to ask out
or
the man has to propose to a woman why
does it have to be like this like i i
don't agree with it i think that if you
really want equality you should have
equality in every field even if it's not
convenient for you you know yeah and
what um
what do you think about like the johnny
depp and amber heard situation
um do you feel like that was the fault
of feminism
i think ember heard definitely used
feminism in a bad way like for herself
and people at first sighted with her
only because she was a woman so they
uh
they assumed that she was right and
because the man is always the bad one
who's beating up women and some people
don't realize that actually it can be
the other way around and thank god that
like uh
johnny actually won the the tryon and it
shows that you know
the justice system is right and they see
through you know people's lives and
things like that yeah yeah no i agree um
why don't you think we see um women
marching the street because
for men that aren't let into bars for
free
because they don't care it's not their
problem is it right yeah
they want equality don't they they want
equality for like they want the same
things as men but they don't care what
men don't have and they have right like
what you said like women have privilege
sometimes because of their looks
um
they get hired in some places instead of
men maybe if there's a
if there's a man in charge they'll get
hired for their looks and i cannot say
that i'm not privileged because of my
looks obviously i know
i just tried to not use it in my
advantage you know i just try to
be myself and you know use my
intelligence or something else as a
you know
tool let's say
okay where are you from london no where
are you from italy okay i i find that um
the more like like eastern i guess in
europe they don't really agree with
feminism as much would you feel like
that's true
i mean i don't know i guess it's not
such a big issue like we're not so
radical about it like obviously we want
to be equal but we are not uh
marching down the streets or or making a
huge problem about it uh if a man
i don't know has more rights than us
like we just tried to fight for it and
uh like even in our private lives you
know do you feel like
equality is possible with anyone like
even me and you we're both we're both
women right but me and you like we're
gonna be unequal in different things so
when people say equality i never know
what they're talking about
yeah because i guess it there's always a
third party that kind of sets the
standards right for equality so
i guess equality just means like same
chances and possibility for everyone but
i don't like to i don't even like the
word equality i think we were talking
about this with some friends i think
equality is never
the right word because people come from
different backgrounds different like
even economical situations so we don't
have the same possibilities so it's
almost like equality of opportunity
would be better than just equality
it's i think
i don't remember the exact word we use
not equality we use like inclusion or
something like that yeah okay well thank
you so much i appreciate it do you have
any socials you want to plug
yes my instagram it's at gabby
underscore dmua i'm a makeup artist
thank you so much i appreciate it
and pearl nice to meet you
um would you identify as a feminist i
would say that i i do yes okay so what
do you think we need feminism for in
2022
um so this girl demanded that she see
this video
the edits before i post it
um so this is just let me letting you
know that no um
you
decided to sit down
and get recorded you don't get to see
what i do with the footage
well in 2022 i think we need feminism
for the equality of all genders and all
sexes and
that's that really so what like like
what specific policy are we fighting for
equality of all sexes and the fact that
men have certain privileges that of
course women don't we don't have the
privilege of walking in the middle of
the night and not being scared that
someone's going to attack us and
were fighting for equality in those
terms and beyond that as well in terms
of you know in the legal world in terms
of uh education in terms of
jobs there's so many things that so to
start men are more likely to be victims
of a violent crime than women
so um
if like and i don't really know what
policy we'd be fighting for because i
think across the board like i i say
grape on youtube i can't say that
i can't say i can't say r-a-p-e
so i'm gonna say great okay like grape
is illegal murder is legal so all
violence is illegal so i just don't know
what policy we're fighting for because
if you just tell
bad guys don't don't grape or don't kill
like they're not going to stop but like
marches aren't going to fix that it's
just law enforcement yeah i agree i i'm
an aspiring embarrasser so i know that
more than anything it is the legal side
of things that
do need to be put in force more
i guess boldly and
solidly to in order for us to actually
achieve equality it's not a thing of oh
what is the one policy that's going to
make this work and that's going to that
what we're fighting for there's so many
things that feminism is fighting for and
you can't sort of box that into a
certain thing and say oh what what is
the one policy you're fighting for i
disagree with that it's not it's not
it's not one policy because to me we are
equal yeah like to me in 2022 i don't
think we need feminism because i don't
think there's anything left to fight for
well i would disagree with that and i
think i don't know where the
conversation would go from that other
than to say
that there are so many things